wenn ich allerdings hier unten ein habe
unter wasser ich hoffe darauf ihr seht
ist anm eine handbewegung ist ich mache
rechtsweg ich kann auch unter wasser
gehen
ihr hört keine sounds die teile
funktioniere nicht unter wasser hallo
ich meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zurück zu einer weiteren
folge der minecraft facts nachdem die
letzten vier minecraft verfolgen alle
vorproduziert wann war ich in urlaub
gefahren ist diese folge mal wieder eine
ganz frische und ich habe auch diesmal
ein passendes geräusch für euch dabei
und dann würde ich sagen
schon direkt damit den fake natürlich
muss ich vorher wie immer sagen ihr
könnt mails ihr könnt mir mail sind
genau ja ihr könnt mir mails senden und
zwei kerne mail mit einem fact seine
eventuelle cool findet ihn allerdings
noch nicht denn gegen dem anderen video
gesehen dass wir ein bisschen uncool
wenn ich sachen vorstellen würde die
schon am anderen videos zu sehen waren
und alles mögliche das geht nämlich
alles an die mail von crafter gmail.com
dieser runde in der beschreibung noch
mal hin geschrieben
da könnt ihr mit fakten schreiben hier
noch nicht bei anderen leuten gesehen
habt und ich kann auch nicht dafür
garantieren dass hier sachen drin
vorkommen die ihr eventuell noch nicht
kennt oder die ihr schon woanders
gesehen hat weil diese serie lebt von
ihren e-mails und ich kann ja nicht
theoretisch jedem helfen mit jedem
vorhandenen video auf youtube abgleichen
blablabla ich mach das mal jetzt noch
eben schnell weil die letzte folge ist
ja schon so lange her
irgendwann in diesem video kommt ein
geheimnisvolles geräusch dann wird sonst
green eingeblendet und bla bla bla und
da steht dann irgendwas sondern habe ich
irgendwas und dann müsst ihr dieses
geräusche erraten
und wenn ihr dieses geräusch erwartet
dann schreibt es und in die kommentare
so schnell wie es geht
oder halt einfach so richtig wie es geht
und eventuell werde in der nächsten
minecraft ex folge erwähnt und wenn ihr
wissen wollt ihr das letzte
geheimnisvolle geräusche vor vier wochen
richtig erraten hat dann bleibt einfach
dran und irgendwo in diesem video kommt
gerne das war das geräusch ich hoffe ihr
hattet und jetzt viel spaß erste fällt
nämlich selber eingefallen und zwar
schon 'ne kiste hingestellt mit allen
möglichen mans bayern
das sind allerdings alles friedlichem
auszusehen hier fährt nuzzolo pilz guten
fisch kuh schwein schaf
wolf und dorfbewohner euch hier schon so
eine kleine wasserfläche mit so reeh
seerosen drauf gemacht und was möchte
ich zeigen ich möchte euch zeigen dass
keiner von diesen friedlichen mops also
bei ein paar aggressiver mops können
drauf stehen aber bei zombies als
kleines bisschen verpackt und so das
bisschen ekelhaft keiner von denen kann
da drinstehen das heißt ich jetzt mal
rein der wolf geht unter selbst wenn das
huhn geht unter setzt man das schaf
daran dass schaaf geht unter ich setzt
man das schweinchen herein
das schweinchen da rein das schweinchen
daran wird das scheint ihn auch unter
die kuka nicht auch mal reinsetzen die
kuh geht nämlich auch unter den
tintenfisch ist klar sehen was hat ihr
die pilze gehen da rein jetzt kommen
gehen beginnen wird die kuh geht auch
unter schubst die mal wieder so ein
bisschen raus lotze lot läuft ihr direkt
weg vor mir aber der geht auch unter das
kann ich euch jetzt weiß nicht wie ich
das zeigen soll aber der läuft halt
direkt weg das kleine ding
okay der wolf getötet auch sein als
manche beispielsweise ein pferd einsätze
geht das pferd auch unter wir da seht
und zu guter letzt wenn ich hier noch
einen dorfbewohner nehme seht ihr auch
beim dorfbewohner der dorfbewohner
scheiß verdenken wenn man erklären beim
dorfbewohner seht ihr auch der
dorfbewohner geht auch unter also keiner
von diesen mops die ich gerade den
winter hatte kann wirklich auf see
rosenblättern laufen die zweite sache
wurde mir zugesendet von niklas und zwar
wenn du einen tunnel hass der zwei
blöcke hoch ist und du vor den eingangs
cent legst kannst du nicht mehr den
tunnel rein das hört sich erst mal blöd
an aber ihr seht schon wenn ich ins auto
und einfach so kahl ausdruck und gesät
ich den stück weiter nach unten so mal
noch mal ist hier ein stück weiter nach
unten sonntag allerdings müsste man ja
eigentlich vermuten okay nur weil ich
ein stück runter gehe heißt es ja dass
ich trotzdem in den tunnel rhein kann
weil eigentlich wenn man ein stück hoch
geht und einfach super und ohne rein zu
gehen dann geht es vielleicht nicht
allerdings geht es so auch nicht ich hab
da einen extra diamanten hin ganz
normaler minecraft wird sagen wow
diamanten will dahin sprinten und sieht
einfach verdammt ich kann ich also ich
gehe gerade nach vorn ich weiß nicht wie
ich das sein soll eventuell sieht man es
beim sprinten
die sieht man auch nicht ihr könnt aber
einfach mal selbst testen ich versuche
gerade nach vorne zu gehen
es geht nicht ich halte wege drückt ich
weiß nicht woran es liegt aber es ist
halt irgendwie nicht möglich wenn der
tunnel zwei blöcke hoch ist wenn er drei
blöcke hoch weil ich dann einfach wieder
darüber meckern oder warte ich zeig euch
mal so mit den drei blöcken dann kann
ich halt dadurch wenn dieser tunnel
allerdings zwei blöcke hoch ist kann ich
da nicht durch und ich komm nicht an die
diamanten also ich könnte eventuell
abbauen aber ich kann sie nicht
einsammeln
herzlichen glückwunsch etwas
geheimnisvolle geräusche jetzt entdeckt
ihr seid super klappt einfach nur das
video angeschaut aber egal
das letzte mal vor vier wochen wird er
das geheimnisvolle geräusche erwähnt
weil ich ja im urlaub war und dann
konnte ich das nicht machen mit aktuell
die geräusche kommentare raussuchen
ich wollte nur ganz kurz sagen dass das
letzte geheimnisvolle geräusche von der
personaldaten wurden eingesendet
eingeblendet und zwar pete smith school
1 und er hat geschrieben habt noch mal
angehört du lässt schlüssel fallen auf
die hand das war glaube ich das geräusch
wo ich an schlüssel der bund hat fallen
lassen und das geräusch für diese folge
was wir raten müsst ist dass hier so
viel glück dabei und jetzt gehts weiter
mit dem fag schreibt seine kommentare
ist effekt kommt ebenfalls von niklas
genauso wie effekt dahin weil der niklas
hat mit 20 sec zugesendet habe ich jetzt
einfach mal drei stück von rausgesucht
ich möchte nicht jeden nehmen weil sonst
die nächsten fünf folgen nur mit facts
von niklas aber halt einfach ein
bisschen zu belohnen dafür dass er mir
20 sec zugesendet hat sind die nächsten
mal auch niklas und zwar der hier ist
ihr seht da unten einen blog unter
wasser einen noten block und die kennt
ganz normal ist das thema noten block
hin wundervolle sieg gewesen wenn man
kann ja auf jeden fall
man kann damit wundervolle musik
erstellen wenn es denn über wasser ist
wenn ich allerdings ich könnte mir hier
einen drauf setzen dann geht's immer
noch so jetzt habe ich zwei übereinander
deswegen hört doch besseres als wenn ich
allerdings hier unten ein habe unter
wasser ich hoffe darauf ihr seht es an
einer handbewegung ist ich mache
rechtsweg ich kann auch unter wasser
gehen
ihr hört keine science die teile
funktioniere nicht unter wasser die
funktionieren über wasser oder wenn sie
halt so im wasser sind aber die spitze
oben wo der sound rauskommt wenn der
halt über wasser ist also wenn er
irgendwie so ist dann geht es nicht ihr
die ganze zeit jetzt nicht also unter
wasser kann man in minecraft keine musik
machen ist ein bisschen traurig aber es
geht ja im echten leben auch nicht ich
mein stellt euch mal vor jemand im
echten leben mit einem klavier unter
wasser und versuchter musik zu machen
dass er noch kein a la times oder der
letzte weg wurde mir ebenfalls mit von
niklas und zwar seht ihr wart ihr denn
überhaupt oscar erhielt niklas kritiker
vergessen irgendwie und zwar haben wir
hier ein paar sachen aufgebaut und zwar
alles so natur naturelle dinge und zwar
haben wir hier auf dem grasbrook haben
wir hier einen normalen fichten
setzlingen oder eichen moment mit
einreichen setzlingen dann haben wir
hier eine ganz normale blaue euch hier
haben wir hohes gras und hier haben wir
auf dem sand einen kaktus und auf sand
noch mal einen zuckerrohr wo ich denke
was an ihm gemacht hat damit er darauf
stehen bleibt und wenn ich jetzt hier
beispielsweise wasser hin kippe seht ihr
dass diese drei sachen natürlich weg
gehen so weil die auf wasser scheiße
reagieren und sein sätzchen geht
natürlich weggespült eine blüte wird
weggespült und ein hohes gras es recht
allerdings wenn ich das hier mal machen
würde wenn ich jetzt mal einfach wasser
hin setzte es prallte daran ab
kakteen und zuckerrohr sind die einzigen
sachen wenn nicht dann wenn sich die
einzigen sind dann berichte ich mich
bitte aber ich meine es sind die
einzigen ist mit den ganzen sachen
getestet habe es in die einzigen sachen
die wasser immun sind also ich könnte
auch eine stufe höher noch wasser machen
das wird jetzt blöd für meine welt weil
die jetzt hier komplett überspült wird
aber ihr seht schon oder auch wenn ich
hierhin setzte also ist vollkommen egal
das ganze bleibt trotzdem stabil ich
kann da was dagegen machen alles möglich
es wird nicht weggesperrt
auch wenn ich das wasser hier dann
wieder wegnehmen ihr seht das ganze
gleich ich kann es auch mal hier
zwischen setzen oder irgendwelche
anderen formationen machen das jetzt
gerade wenn ihr euch fragt warum der weg
gegangen ist nur weil ich den blog
hingesetzt habe
im wissen dass wenn ich eine kakteen
kaktus hinsetzen box nebenan geht der
weg aber nicht wegen dem wasser also was
quasi auch im block den ich neben den
charakter setzte aber da geht es nicht
weg das kann ich euch nochmal hier
zeigen sorgt dann geht's nämlich nicht
erst wenn ich dann log in seite geht der
kaktus kaputt also das ist auf jeden
fall der coole sache um zu erkennen was
alles kaputt geht wenn man da wasser
hinsetzt und dann will ich sagen dass
mit der heutigen folge wenn es euch
gefallen hat zeigt mit einer bewertung
und eventuell habt ihr das
geheimnisvolle geräusche erraten was an
irgendeiner stelle dazu gekommen ist
dann benötigte geben wie der nächste
nächsten dienstag bitte an konnte auf
der thema dot com